[Musik]
ein luzerner unternehmer erlebt das
schwierigste jahr seines lebens am
antwort schreibt brunner setzt der firma
stark zu eine künstlerin hofft bis
zuletzt dass sie auf tournee gehen kann
[Musik]
ein 50-jähriger familienvater steht vor
einer unsicheren zukunft
[Musik]
arbeitslos
es ist zwei hotelbetreiber lassen sich
von der krise nicht entmutigen
ihre geschichten in luzern im corona ja
[Musik]
luzern im februar 2021 läden und museen
sind geschlossen
sogar die traditionelle lozärner
fasnacht muss ausfallen
das jahr mit der pandemie hinterlässt
spuren
die menschen werden corona müde roland
kühn der ceo der festzelt baufirma
hunziker hatte im letzten jahr einen
verlust von 1,3 millionen franken zu
verkraften
hunziker gehört zur messe league und in
wetzikon der oberste chef hat roland
kühn einbestellt andreas messerli
besitzt neun firmen die auf live und
digital anlässe spezialisiert sind
online spricht er zu seinem team und
drückt seine begeisterung über die
impfungen aus gute nachrichten für jetzt
auch heißt nämlich die pandemie hat es
aber haftung
das ist klar live ist live findet live
statt um ihr werdet sehr stark zurück
blieben gesund mixa danke vielmals
andreas messerli gibt roland king einen
einblick in die messe welt der zukunft
wo man wirklich sehr viele hunde jetzt
handeln
da geht es natürlich darum wie wir kann
man nach selbst vor der zukunft machen
kommen virtuell machen
mit den tools und dann hat einen punkt
beschrieben wird probiert man sozusagen
doch die schlafstatt komplize ganz
langsam wo wir noch mal ne brille ja wie
intensiv das ist also das man sich sagen
das ist der größte unterschied zwischen
salih und hunziker mehr betriebe sondern
auch im bereich und der zahlt zahlt
politik hat es wird vom meister
verwünscht wie ihr könnt auf digital
umstellen
15 patienten vorstellen
quasi war und doch glaubt messerli an
hunziker und das haben wir mit mit
hunziker kunde das heißt hunziker werde
mir also ganz ich alles machen damit
sich wieder wieder unser hund also das
ist ganz wichtig für gruppen ist wichtig
will einfach sie sind erforscht
systemrelevant für für die branche oder
das können sie ja das tut unheimlich gut
wenn man das gehört und das center werde
dir die hoffnungsvoll beruf sport und
weiß wie so was das ausmacht schon wie
so was twitter macht schule in der krise
sieht andreas messerli sogar seine große
chance
gottes damit im abstand ich danke daher
danke dann bitteschön der vision für
dänemark begleitet
es ist ruhig es ist sehr ruhig der
eintritt problem größere schätze so soja
oder das fans im frühling metzlos gold
lena schwarz vereinter und und ich
glaube schlagartig aus gold das wird
sicher nicht
das sind ganz große chance natürlich der
große wiese gesehen die den marc gene
und wann jeder wowereit jeder wo
kooperationen so recht natürlich ist das
ist klar und wenn man die jetzt endlich
klarheit hand hier aus wie die schweiz
bringen dann tut mir das sehr genau
prüfen
ja wirke sei der winter da wollen wir
jetzt natura und dann löst sich dann das
sport sport frühlingsmarkt stimmen ab
dem optimismus angesagt oder unheimlich
gut stimmt sich mit viel hilfe andere
das geht einfach die entlastung im kopf
dann deutlich und damit ganz wieder
planbar
die expansionspläne seines chefs machen
roland können neuen mut
bojan jovanovic hat einen schweren gang
vor sich
[Musik]
25 jahre hatte er beim souvenirhändler
casagrande als hauswart gearbeitet
im herbst erhielt er wegen der korona
krise die kündigung
jetzt muss sich der 50-jährige beim
arbeitsamt anmelden
zum ersten mal in seinem leben jetzt wie
lange sind sie tätig 25 jahre mit
wirklich harten brocken
denn was sie von uns bildungsniveau was
einzig lernen automonteur klettern nach
dränge handelsschule und englisch krebs
und ein wenig nach der tourismus-branche
je nach okay und ich wählen werde ich so
ist sie zu stellen schwieriger moment
immobilie gebäude sehr schwer mit mir
und immobilienbewirtschaftung die
muttersprache deutsch hat jetzt eine
andere sprache bis sehr gut gut okay
eigentlich englisch also dann habe ich
ja fast noch fragen oder ist sogar gut
so wie sich das gut und heinz frage von
mir das auf jeden fall
danke danke
[Musik]
es braucht aber man sieht dass in der
arbeitslosigkeit die menschen das
realisiert man noch nicht so ganz
noch vor kurzem war bojan der allseits
geschätzte mann für alle fälle
jetzt geht er in eine ungewisse zukunft
auf dem see taal platz in emmenbrücke
steht die älteste jahrmarkt bude der
schweiz mit viel hingabe und herzblut
renovieren claudia kienzler und ihr team
das über 70-jährige varieté-theater wind
und wetter haben den schildern arg
zugesetzt
mit viel sorgfalt hat schriften male
severin maier die nostalgischen schilder
neu gemalt diese verleihen der bude
frischen glanz
[Musik]
funktioniert das urteil aus alt und neu
ich war das entscheidungsspiel sie nicht
zu machen und das theater sprache wurde
unterschriften braucht und das ist ja
wie ein wink für 100 euro mit interesse
usa in diesem frühling will die
40-jährige auf schweizer tournee gehen
aber aufgrund des schleppenden verlaufs
der pandemie an sie dass sie ihren plan
wohl nicht wird verwirklichen können
infrastruktur um mir das ganze macht und
baut und srs wachst und künstlerische
idee erhöht und die sätze mit regie und
gleichzeitig schrumpft möglichkeit oder
dem schritt vision dass es dort
sachlicher starten ab anfang märz 2021
öffnen in luzern museen und läden
das hauptgeschäft von casa grande ist
nur am wochenende offen
souvenirhändler robert casagrande sieht
wie sich das bild der altstadt verändert
hat hier wo mietpreise teilweise schon
seit mehreren jahren überhöht sind
mussten um die 20 geschäfte schließen
andere finden keine mieter corona hat
diese krise verstärkt wo man
international wo koppel pace jeder
starken auskurieren und nutzer haben
muss nicht die ideen gebiet und musste
angebot hawo ursache findet überall hin
das hört sich frei wurden er hatte die
selber interessiert 47 und maxim ihr da
mache dies einem lappen
dank der diät oder casagrande ist ein
guter platz und hat aber nicht so erfolg
und jetzt mit corona ich maschine das
geld ausgegangen und hat minister zu
machen wird von jedem verkauften kaffee
gehen zehn prozent der einnahmen an
casagrande für den standplatz
[Musik]
claudia kienzler die geschäftsführerin
des varieté kaleidoskop bekommt
tatkräftige unterstützung von ihrer
mutter ursula
[Musik]
ursula scherer mag dass buemi ambiente
auf dem platz doch das war nicht immer
so
als wir haben nicht gefunden auch so
cool aber ich habe verstanden dass ich
sehr gern
[Musik]
diese vorhänge wurden schon im alten
variete benutzt
in ungezählten arbeitsstunden hat ihnen
claudias mutter jetzt zu einem neuen
auftritt verholfen
[Musik]
wenn der vorhang öffnet oder sowie die
edle dre hund wird zum theater und das
coole drinks bietet mit vorhängen oder
eigentlich wenig ist wahnsinnig viel
charme schaffen sagt wahl
[Musik]
das ist die klassische kultur
nehmen wir einen vorraum aufgaben denn
ist klar ich bin nicht die einzige und
ich glaube menschen freut sich
wahnsinnig drauf bist vorhang mit ruf
könnt und wir werden den moment nutzen
parat sie mit dem mittel wirklich stein
auftrieb regung auf
[Gelächter]
nicht weit vom varieté entfernt ist das
zuhause von bojan jovanovic und seine
familie noch vor wenigen monaten hatte
er einen 100% schon jetzt muss er seine
tage neu strukturieren
die korona thematik treibt ihn um man
probiert sich was wenn ich also mit sehr
viel informationen liest
beschäftigungsprogramm für sich selbst
finden
der entlassene hausrat ist auf sinnsuche
spirituelle spiel mehr wert als
materielle was mir leider mit dem sid
vergessen und mit materielle versuchen
und wider der spirituelle finde aber ja
gebrütet
vorsicht da wo jetzt echter mögen das
materielle weitere und die studieren und
dem stelle zb internet sachen sand oder
wasser und bier nimmt es gelassen
bekannt sind
seit anfang jahr sucht er nach einer
neuen stelle
doch der 50 jährige allrounder ohne
diplom muss schmerzlich erkennen dass
seine chancen begrenzt sind
technische definition was ist wirklich
böses erwachen für mich weil es ist
nicht so wie man sich vorgestellt hat
jetzt sucht meistens gleich alter und
erklärt das ist vor 30 jahren und
arbeite mit bildet habe ich mich im casa
grande aktivieren
[Musik]
von marc bartl
ich hoffe dass es jetzt kritisch hieß es
meistens damit absage und das
schriftlich elektronisch mit nina ist wo
er seit 27 jahren verheiratet
sie arbeitet teilzeit als verkäuferin im
moment schaffe ich viel weniger
reduziert worden dass ihr mann in dieser
wirtschaftlich angespannten zeit keinen
job hat belastet nina viel mehr aber das
ist glaube jedem gleich es macht schon
angst will aber das könnte einfach nur
vor allem jetzt mit einer corona
situation blut verliert jobs also nicht
nur die bayern also viele hände
existenzprobleme das ist sehr schlimm
und ja irgendwie nicht versuche jetzt
positiv blieben dank ihres coaches aber
auf den briten
irgendwie kann ich das es könnte jetzt
nicht auf
[Musik]
der grendel war vor corinna der hotspot
des lozärner tourismus trotz guter lage
hat das luxusgeschäft das zum gaza
grander imperium gehört fast keine
kundschaft doch heute erwartet robert
casagrande eine überraschung
[Musik]
am ende war unschön york aufhält und ob
es ist schon abgeschlossen und schöne
startet dagegen solche einträglichen
verkäufe sind viel zu selten
darum gibt es ein corona
alternativprogramm
im boudoir für luxuriöse spieluhren
werden jetzt gesichtsbehandlungen
angeboten dass man sich vorstelle liter
auf dem stuhl grundlegung der musik groß
aber spielt das ist ja bisher einmaliges
erlebnis aber zu wenig lukrativ fast
alle 100 mitarbeitenden sind in
kurzarbeit die anderen versucht der
patron aufzumuntern
er hoffe das ist doch ein paar league
geht wo in europa um ein android tablet
pc vor dem herr werden wir sicher über
das tor von lofer und heute schon gut
losgegangen und hoffe dass es weiterhin
heute so läuft damit der guten tag hat
und dass man alle freuten
[Gelächter]
ich bin überzeugt dass so ein diesem
herbst die hier studiert werden
individuell aber das natürlich 34 jahre
gab es mehrere feindliche zauber sind
wie vorher
und aus dem grund dass es immer
natürlich sehr zufrieden das ist der
staat hilft die übergangszeit casagrande
will dass das familienunternehmen auch
in dritter generation weitergeführt
werden kann
mit dem schönen wetter über die
ostertage können sich die menschen eine
auszeit
das hotel wo sie jurist aus dem
winterschlaf erwacht
eineinhalb monate war es geschlossen
manuel berger und walter willimann
inspizieren die vergrößerte terrasse
zusammen mit dem besitzer haben sie sie
im winter eigenhändig umgebaut
also warum man muss man dagegen halten
habe sofort ja das ist so
über die ostertage sind alle 28 zimmer
ausgebucht diese gäste sind in genf
wohnhafte experts gleich über die straße
wir haben ein parkplatz für sie kamen
wir nach luzern
wir haben frei und wir wollten eine
auszeit
[Musik]
wieso ausgerechnet luzern wegen der
museen und dem sonnigen strand direkt am
strand
[Gelächter]
eine tasse tee bitte schwarztee
aber auch gäste aus luzern freuen sich
über einen tapetenwechsel
[Musik]
endlich wie der arbeit der hoteldirektor
stieg gleich selbst in der küche event
wieder zu sehen und sie waren trotz
kleiner ganze corona geschichte und im
moment ist es eigentlich sehr erfreulich
für den moment hatte ich so ein anderes
was gott und meine frau lisa baumeister
mit kommen was sie sagen
nach vielen höhen und tiefen im letzten
jahr hat manuel den glauben zurück
gewonnen dass das hotel russisch uhr
eine zukunft hat
[Musik]
im frühling mit dem varieté kaleidoskop
auf schweizer tournee gehen das war der
herzenswunsch von claudia kienzler und
ihrem freund christoph spielmann
doch daraus wird leider nichts
entscheiden die probe starte und trennen
umstand und ein die zunächst verschoben
das sind extrem schwierige entscheidung
weil der patient wissen will was die
türe auf
trotz der großen enttäuschung arbeiten
die beiden weiter am bühnenprogramm
[Musik]
aber namen wird es auch künftig keine
geben
ausfall entschädigungen sind ungewiss
das ist druck wohne ich merke in der
nacht unterm berg und immer wieder diese
energie was mir geht es wieder wenn man
drinnen proben machen und das ist das
ist also man das crowdfunding am start
wo bis ende mai läuft wo man wenn die
gelder generieren für die rechtliche
institution als für die finisher zum das
jagdrennen über glaube ohne die einnahme
[Musik]
so hält claudia amm traum vom fahrenden
jahrmarkt theaterfest artistik musik und
kulinarik als gegenprogramm zur welt
draußen
wie wacklig und unsicher ist und wo
immer wieder der absturz droht die
idealvorstellung ist dass mir das ja
doch noch wenn es war ihr dem linie von
matthias quas es bush korrigieren da vor
ort neutralem erfahren
doch die schlechteste variante ist dass
es ist luft
an bester lage direkt am see liegt das
vier sterne hotel kastanienbaum hier
macht bojan jovanovic ein praktikum dass
er vom regionalen
arbeitsvermittlungszentrum zugewiesen
bekommen hat das hotel war lange zeit
geschlossen das hat spuren hinterlassen
der neue direktor jonas die barbie führt
bojan am ersten arbeitstag durchs haus
sind das heißt man tritt noch öl und im
zeit- und im dritten stock ist zum
beispiel noch gar nicht gemacht wie ist
es mit einem kühlschrank also belüftung
oder der genau richtig drum leute die
sagen das ist ein system momentan sind
und auch des nachts großes thema wird
arzt auch sie womit ein reiniger und
dann möchte ich den mann hat einfach
diese habe nachhaltig
[Musik]
einige flik story technik und sobald das
erledigt hat und denkt sich gut dass
neustadt
es gibt sehr viel zu natürlich muss die
ganze aufgabe bereich zusammenfasst
würdest du dir ja es ist sehr
interessant
[Musik]
im keller ist borjans künftige werkstatt
gebracht worden
kein vergleich zur b1 früheren
arbeitsplatz bei casagrande muss auf
jeden fall wieder komplettieren
aber da würde sagt ja immer nur das ist
wieder ein vorrat ich habe da stellt
sich also verbrachten gesellschafterin
glaube ist da so bald wird es ganz
einfach der wahnsinn einfach daheim mit
unseren job tierisch ja da ist sehr sehr
sehr viel arbeit
b
nach dem rundgang ist der direktor
überzeugt vom mann für alle fälle schon
rufe spannende inputs für ich gemerkt
permanent doch wohin soll das ist auch
stoßen mir persönlich sehr hohen oder
betätigt zu einer messe hat finde ich
sehr gut und sehr spannend zudem glaube
ich ist richtig im auto zum das ganze
schöne bikes zu verhindern
ich glaube ich krieg das schon
das ist nicht so ein problem arbeit habe
ich mir nascar und herberich zeit weil
sind prioritäten und das braucht aber
zeit
praktiker klasse komme übrigens
[Musik]
vielleicht ist es nicht borjans traumjob
aber immerhin ist er auf dem
arbeitsmarkt wieder gefragt
[Musik]
in ibach bei luzern bereiten bagger den
boden für ein neues projekt vor
ein provisorium im rahmen eines umbaus
des kantonsspitals der auftrag geht an
die firma hunziker aus willisau
das motiviert sie auch roland kühn und
seinen projektleiter
damals noch daran eigentlich im prinzip
sofort war
zwar nicht brandschutzbeauftragte oder
sich ein provisorium für die
rettungsteams stunden 440
containerschiffe früh schweres spiel
werde ich und jetzt wo das für größeren
und trage so doch ein paar regentropfen
zwei jahren schaffen und das natürlich
sehr sehr kurz schaut nicht erwähnt wird
stark vom band kommt ja es geht wieder
hoffnung auf dass monica hat auf der das
innere ist kein hartes altenhofen und
heute sagen kann man zusammen und wird
[Musik]
das 86-jährige unternehmen ist in einem
historischen tief weil es nicht
behördlich geschlossen worden ist hat es
außer kombikredit und kurzarbeit
zuschüssen erst jetzt härtefall gelder
erhalten obwohl der umsatz um 85 prozent
eingebrochen ist ein hartes jahr für
roland klinger jobprofile vom
geschäftsführer zum krisenmanager mit
personalvermittlern zum glück probieren
unterzubringen irgendwo krise zu machen
zwar nicht auf diesem business völlig
fremde sachen probiert auftrag jetzt
ziehe und dank hauptaufgabe ist ob aus
einem reinfall motivator pfalz bank of
scotland mit sie als zeichen welches gas
corp
und so werden die flachen wohl noch
lange in der lagerhalle bleiben bis im
frühling 2022 sei es für seine branche
gelaufen sagt kühn
aber der unternehmer gibt nicht auf
bis das ihn umgibt oder fusioniert
[Musik]
ein jahr wie kein anderes liegt hinter
uns
jede und jeder hat einen eigenen weg
durch die krise finden müssen
dabei wurden wir alle mit der frage
konfrontiert was wirklich wichtig ist im
leben versucht mich nicht ich nackt
ausziehen wenn ich die zeit wie ich mir
absolut bewusst dass es mir viel besser
dort aus einem anderen land
[Musik]
mit dem jahr hat erklärt wie fest dass
man auf sich selbst gestellt ist und es
ist also niemand zu machen
schlussendlich und du für dich da sie
und wieder los
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
interviewpartnerin geschäftspartnern und
ja mit viel tapferkeit in zukunft laufen
und einfach vorwärts machen
ich persönlich hat das noch nie erlebt
die mitarbeiter sehen wir geschafft ich
habe bisher so komplett schwierig läuft
und ich glaube dass moderiert persönlich
nicht mehr mit was man vielleicht dieser
zukunftstechnologie taxi
[Musik]
ich persönlich nehme eine riesige
erfahrungsschatz mit aus dem jahr der
grund optimismus behalten und der
schwung der partner wenn es immer mal
wieder drückt
[Musik]
am morgen charlotte roche und der hat
verantwortung als unternehmer eines
steht dabei mit 150 betten unternehmen
kämpft und seitenhalt und so heißt es
auch weiterhin in luzern und anderswo
durchhalten und die hoffnung nicht
aufgeben
[Musik]